we kick off our number-3 here on day
number four by welcoming in a future
hall-of-famer from the Dallas Cowboys
and here courtesy of our friends my
friends and our friends at Marriott good
to see Jason Witten how are you sir good
to see you sir I'm going well it's good
to have you here president of the
Courtyard by Marriott and you know it is
amazing I've been with them forever in a
day and you're here we're gonna be
hanging out tomorrow night at their
party here in downtown Miami and the
event that they they have every year and
to celebrate the winner of the Super
Bowl sleepover contest where somebody
gets to win a chance to sleep in the
stadium on Saturday night it's
unbelievable and then they wake up and
they wake up the next day for Super
Sunday in this spot it's truly
unbelievable yeah it's pretty cool you
know a few years back I went with them
and I had breakfast with one of the
winners that's you in the morning yeah
and did you deliver it like to the do
you knock on the door and don't know
they knew that I was gonna be there okay
so I just got to hang out have breakfast
and be at the Super Bowl site and I just
think you know what a neat experience
for us to be able to kind of engage with
those fans sure of course
what courtyards providing for them and
get to wake up you know and see it go
from being the only people in the
stadium to then when it explodes so I
know and I remember two years ago in
Maya and Minnesota I was hanging out in
the again they remake him entire suite
in a stadium into a courtyard by Marriot
room and that's where I watched the
Philly special that I went down and I
saw the Philly special right there on
the ground and the whole place was just
losing their minds because that was the
one of the most surprising plays I've
ever seen in my entire life and
obviously you know it was a it was a
heck of a Superbowl what type is
Superbowl do you think we're gonna get
here on Sunday I think it's gonna be a
great game I really do you know I go
back and forth I mean my gut just says I
mean the Chiefs I just think quad in the
home so so good Andy Reid
I love how just he's reinvented himself
now going up to Kansas City and how they
do it but look I mean anytime you can
run the football and play good defense
and get after the quarterback like
that's
formula that is what that lasted for 60
years it's right minute bail so every
time I catch myself kind of jumping on
the Kansas City train I'm reminded hey
what wins in this league and San
Francisco has that formula so I think
it's really a great game and and I think
I think Kansas City pulls it out man you
and I are a lockstep Jason because I've
been trying to hold my horses all week
long to not just say this is mahomes
--is moment that this is going to be his
time to shine
I started the show by saying and my
buddy Brockman over there called me a
hot take artist on the spot that that
that mahomes is way too they here that's
Jason the most talented quarterback to
play in the history of the Super Bowl to
show up thank you I understand that but
talented coming in with a skill set at
the age that he is does not like some 35
year old that's found a Fountain of
Youth
he's not like some guy who's a pocket
passer he's gonna prevent you from the
neck up he's a guy that you have no idea
what's gonna happen and you have no idea
how he can break contain you have no
idea if he's gonna be able to just sling
it no look again I'm getting caught up
in it admittedly but every single time I
do get caught up in that I do think well
man Nick Bose is a totally different
beast that many people are that front
forefront 7 or front 5 as married you
just called it as as talented as they
come yeah and that's when I kind of pull
back a little bit but you are you just
you you would I think it's a bold
statement but I do think you know all
the hype of how good he is I think he's
even better than that and and I say that
in and I believe his ability to create
of he can do it inside the pocket and
escape it he can do it long he's
unbelievable with these rpoS the body
positions I mean that Aaron Rodgers
ability to kind of throw it in these
awkward off-balance spots I mean I was
calling the game a couple years ago or
last year for Monday Night Football
crying he switched hands and throw it
left-handed
again stamp remember that so and I think
he is the ultimate competitor he's been
down he's lost on the road he's played
against Tom Brady he's done against he's
gone to New England and had those type
of games so to be as young as he is yes
he's pretty weathered he's got some
scars you know I mean he's uh he's had
some of those experiences so with that
and knowing the relationship with Andy
Reid yes and the wizard behind the whole
thing of drawing up these plays and he's
got talent around him and he's not
afraid to get them the ball well his
talent again overcomes mistakes they
overcome what normally conventionally
can't be overcome like say your kneecap
being on the side of your leg yeah where
I saw that I'm like okay his season's
over it's over and I certainly didn't
think okay it's not over but he'll be
back in three weeks and Andy Reid's
gonna throw him out there two weeks
before bye and one week before he goes
to Mexico City where they had to cancel
a game because of the turf you know but
nope he goes out there and dominates all
the losses because of circumstances in
Tennessee but he threw for 400 yards
yeah does go to Mexico City doesn't look
any worse than where it does win that
game against the Chargers then he goes
on his bye week or in the AFC
championship game they felt down behind
again team made mistakes certainly
towards the end of the game when they
titans looked like they could come back
with a fake punt he just throws one down
the field yeah and that's why I'm saying
at his age and his position and and his
talent that he could be the most
talented guy to ever play in that spot I
mean you know me I'm not a hot take
artist yeah well I don't trade in that
sort of stuff yeah that's true you're
right I mean but time will tell but I
mean there is something there and I mean
on top of his ability he's just one hell
of a kid too you know which I think as
veteran players you look back and say
alright that's how you should go about
it you know and it was a play in the AFC
Championship game where he kind of
scrambled and was buying some time like
he does all script and look like Tyreke
he'll maybe stopped running because why
wouldn't he's not gonna throw this thing
60 yards and he threw it away I'm not
real sure where he threw it but he got
up and
it caught him like he was so mad he
parked it yeah it kind of barked at him
and that just shows the way the guys
wired which I think that when I see that
I'm like wow I mean he expects to make
those type of plays and so when you're
in the big stage and you can kind of
create those type of plays and expect to
do so and you're you got this type of
skill set he has around him right
watch out but hey listen let's not
forget the other side I know I know that
in there they're very good bands they
don't they are terrific and and I do
think it's gonna be a very evenly
matched Super Bowl Jason Witten here on
the Rich Eisen show which tight end do
you think is gonna have the most impact
Kittel or Kelsey both I mean they're the
number one weapons for their offense and
there's a lot of good players I mean
across the board I'm on buckler's the
skill group right they're just so
dynamic both of those guys I mean I mean
kid older probably a little bit more in
the run game I mean cuz he they want to
get that zone game gone and takes a lot
of pride and that but I mean Kelsey's
just not only does he have feel and the
connection with the quarterback but he's
so explosive to be that big and he just
knows where that spot is you know he
just finds that that sauce spot and he
gets first down so they're both I expect
a huge gain from him we had a con
earlier Jason and he you know said he's
confident that there's gonna be a deal
but the fact that there isn't one still
as kind of it's just weird there's just
no other way to put it what what what
happened last year in Dallas that that
caused the team to not make the playoffs
not succeed as many expected can you put
something on it here I I mean we just
didn't play very well down critical
stretch and we had every opportunity
with the division being what it was I
just think it boils down to you know the
league as a whole it's tight games
it's like 75% of the games are one score
in the fourth quarter we lost seven of
eight games and so at once since you
look at it you say oh it's close right
there you know
we can any those games can go either way
right but then the other since is like
well good teams find ways to win those
type of games and we just couldn't do
that and had opportunities down the
stretch so just collectively I think
both sides we didn't play as well I mean
it's a talented roster certainly should
be better than eight and that's tough
when your season ends and you don't you
know you you don't catch that break and
no one you had that many opportunities
but I don't think it had anything to do
with tax contract I mean that guy's just
a pro right he handles it and I'm
confident those guys will get that
resolved and he'll be the quarterback
there for a long time what about you are
you done playing no I don't think so
you know I'm gonna take a little time
and I've had one go around at this and I
know it's debatable on how that ended up
for me they're rich but I just want to
be deliberate in the process of knowing
what it takes to play but I'm proud of
the way I played I think you don't want
to make another run at that okay and and
I know this the opportunity to play when
that leaves it's it's over you know I
mean a big part of me has been kind of
tied to coaching and I want to get into
coaching and make a difference that way
but it's a lot of time to coach very
little time left for me to play sure
know so got a little time to make that
decision but yeah I think I'm leaning
towards that and get myself ready but
the same time kind of respecting that
process and being deliberate in it
because if there's one thing I learned
it was like when I took the money night
gig maybe I wasn't ready to give it up
but we're all in the business of taking
advantage of opportunities working
himself and that was one that couldn't
pass up but after going through that I
think it's made me take a little bit
more time as I kind of get prepared for
making this decision now have you and
McCarthy connected at all we have yeah
we met okay a really good visit with
Mike you know I mean very honest and
direct I mean we've known each other
from from afar I played for him a couple
of times in the Pro Bowl and obviously
got a lot of respect for him so just a
lot of great conversations with him with
Stephen with Jerry and we'll stay in
communication but I think he's
inheriting a really talented team and
sure
great opportunity for him what would you
consider playing for another team I
think I mean obviously you would have 16
years in Dallas and the words that you
would love to finish it off there but I
also um understand and not naive enough
to think that hey I mean need to be
somewhere else you know I think that's
that's how this business works you know
and so you have to be open to that idea
for sure but I think the biggest thing
is just having those open conversations
with Jerry and Steven and Mike and see
where this thing takes is here in the
next couple months so you would be it
you could see yourself potentially in a
uniform that doesn't have the star in
the Sun yeah it's crazy to say that hey
man look great Brady might have the
decision coming up in about six weeks
yeah you know it's a fact that may
actually come up and a lot of people
think you would not consider it I odd I
think you would consider it yeah I sure
with any time you have a new coach come
in and opportunity I think it's the most
important thing for a veteran player
like myself right what's the role what
do you expect them for me here's my
expectations going into that right it's
about finding that fit I mean when you
get to this point in your career it's
winning and knowing where you're gonna
contribute that's all it is right and
regardless of what you've done in the
past I mean that's how you have to look
at it and so you know when I make those
decisions I know how much I put into it
and everything else kind of goes on hold
and in my life you know and so that's
why I'm kind of taking my time as I go
through it we'll see though the NFL
season for Marriott bound boy members
bid more points you can bid their points
on more than 250 money can't buy
experiences including brunch with NFL
legends like you and experienced Super
Bowl 54 from a luxury suite as well as
on-field access to watch the Pepsi Super
Bowl 50 for halftime showed no better
time to be a Marriott Bomboy member and
of course Courtyard by Marriott is in
its ninth year as the official hotel of
the National
football they it's been an unbelievable
run so I'll be seeing you tomorrow night
at the at the courtyard bash correct
yeah I'll do that
okay fantastic and Denise I've not met
her yet a man I believe is her name she
won the sleep Superbowl sleepover
contest that's a good times so we'll be
hanging out tomorrow I'll look forward
to that she's an ER doctor she's always
that right you better you know I have
not okay tomorrow night
so you actually you actually know what
you're dependent fantastic I look
forward to seeing you man yeah well I'll
see you tomorrow night always love love
seeing you here yeah big fan of the show
man the tribute to the old man your pops
that was great it was great thanks I may
or may have not shed a tear itself you
know what there's been a lot of Tears
shedding around here these days - it's
just just wearing it on your sleeve is
the only way I know how to do it thank
you for saying yeah I think in general
when you're you have this platform to be
around the titans of the industry like
Kobe Bryant you know and salmon shedding
those tears it's like you you can learn
so much from those guys you know and I
think that's what makes this game this
weekend so fun is getting around be able
to share those experiences so many great
ones and uh Kobe sure was that no doubt
did you ever meet him or you ever never
get a couple times and we weren't really
close or anything but just he had that
line of can't cheat the Meuse you know
and he would share that with me actually
we were going up fronts up in New York
City and we got to spend some time
together and huh I just loved how his
mindset was you know when you when you
go to work and outwork them and train
them and everything he was so successful
and I think he made everybody around him
better you know and he never came off
that standard great to see so thoughts
and prayers are for that family
absolutely and for everybody else who
perished in that helicopter accident
putting two and two together when you
were doing up fronts for Monday Night
Football he was probably doing the ESPN
Plus stuff yeah remember he was breaking
stuff down and it was tremendous yeah it
was funny because uh he was talking
about the he saw when I retired there's
a big talk about the Y option route that
was kind of my route it's like a eight
to ten yard get open round yeah and he
was just so amazed into and wanted to
know about all the intricacies that go
into running that rap and what happens
when the well how do you defend it well
what's the challenge what's next how you
going to get better at it you know
just over and over and over and so for
me to be able to spend that time with
him and pick his brain I just think
that's one of the great memories I think
having this opportunity and this
platform is that you get to be around
guys like yeah of course you know and
you know he also was a die-hard Eagles
fan sure he watched a lot of your games
nobody's perfect ha ha ha good to see
you man good to see you at Jason Witten
on Twitter at real Jason Witten on
Instagram and again everybody could
check out what's going on Courtyard by
Marriott by going to the Courtyard by
Marriott website everybody here that is
Jason Witten for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel - 39 on
DirecTV for free on BR Live or download
the Rich Eisen show app